okay now I had some questions about this
one so let's try and unpack what's going
on I will point out by the way that you
see how and please like this sound
there's two parts to this question in
the HSC you will often get these sort of
two-part questions and in the first part
they'll say hey can you prove this
here's a number you should be able to
get there can you demonstrate how you do
that however Paulo reason why they're
doing it this way is they've broken one
question into two pieces so that if you
screw this up that's okay because you
can still take this and use it in the
next part even if you really have no
idea how to do that okay and some people
would do it like I was very confused let
me show you the way that I did it okay
do you remember much space on the board
do you remember that we said there are
two ways of working out for you okay and
they both work but one is quicker than
the other if I don't say $500 over the
course of my four weeks right
and that's my normal wage I can say well
what is the loading on top of this okay
and if it's seventeen and a half percent
I will multiply by 17 the 5% I don't
give me some okay okay now you would
then take that 80 the horns and you'd
say well I want that before we come
right so I would say five hundred plus
that Amy and that's gonna give me the
total amount and talk about it's
important to me because you can see up
in purple hair that's the piece of
information that I'm nerv right this is
actually the preservation they give me
and I need to be able to have sort of
that tractor now as method 1 method 2 is
quicker but it was you have to think of
in there right instead of saying do the
loading and then add them together
you can just start with your original
amount and you can multiply by a
percentage that has the original amount
and the learning together remember what
that was instead of just 17 maja percent
by itself yeah I'm gonna multiply by a
hundred and seventeen and a half percent
but 100 represents the original amount
and the seventeenth an opposite
represents the extra I'm not I'm not
sure if we do our numbers right it
should equal the same amount and the
reason why I'm pointing this out is
because the second method community
helps you more when you're trying to go
backwards do you see this right because
here you've got to go backwards through
two steps but here you just have to go
to backwards through one so instead of
multiplying by a hundred seventeen and a
half percent I'm ready here I'm going to
buy and that should be even better
my question was when I I think I need to
yes and then the second time I went back
and did point five when they gave me to
answer yes yes so let me let me try and
see what's going on at least if I
understand correctly is this what you
burn some said yeah so I want you to all
see why this is it sort of makes sense
but then it leads you to ponder it leads
you to the wrong answer
do you notice that this is actually this
is the final amount this is where I
ended right so it doesn't really make
sense to think about seventeen a half
percent of this number because this is
after the seventeen half percent has
already been added on to that make sense
so when you do this you're treating the
two thousand four hundred eight dollars
it says you're treating that as the
original map the normal pay without any
loading but look it's already got
loading in there right so therefore when
you apply this it's like learning you're
loading so that's why it gets confused
you'll get a different number out here
and it won't work out right now you're
trying to add visenteno percent back and
you might end up with this number okay
so that's why I think probably the most
direct way is the way that I show you up
you want to take that whole amount and
what it represents is a hundred and
seventeen sorry a hundred and seventeen
a half percent it's the original amount
and the loading as well you divide
through you'll get to another
straightaway okay now what just quick
note I'll because I saw some people do
this it's fine there is one other way to
do this question this it's pretty
similar said if you wanted to try to do
his assent enough said maybe the way
you're doing because they tell you it
should be this this is what the original
page should be you can multiply that by
seventeen but half percent and you will
get I don't know 350 or so okay and then
if you add that on you should arrive at
the number that they provided to you
that's what that also is showing that
then without loading will give you that
amount
it's absolutely darling okay I think
this way is more direct but that's okay
there are many parts to a question yep
so I guess the way I would expect to see
that is I would say choose I would say
learning equals to zero four nine sixty
times the 17 and a half percent and that
will give me another and then I will say
um total pay equals of the two zero four
nine and sixty plus whatever that
loading was that you worked out and that
number should be the two four zero eight
to a that is what we are expecting so as
we're quiet that's what I would say like
I said that's fine you get there but do
you see it's like it's a bit securities
this one yeah that's okay because that's
fine yeah that's equivalent okay
so what I am looking for there what
would really help is if there's some
kind of language that explains what's
happening so yes yeah yeah yeah yeah so
that is that's fine that's okay however
like I said or you're having these
numbers they're like your site and
you'll see this for the later question
you starting to go away from showing and
demonstrating that something is the case
right I want to argue in the
demonstrators you understand what the
differences are between all of these
numbers right
that's why can you see I start right out
the gate and say they've been wages
without loading up and then I
demonstrate I know exactly what I'm
talking about as opposed to is that know
or without loading like that's kind of
what's being assessed okay okay great
questions let's move on the next is less
complicated you can see I have elected
to do it in two steps just so again I
can demonstrate exactly I know what I'm
doing
so yeah that's okay I mean like I said I
would prefer to see some words there
that indicate I know what I'm doing like
what is this number I'm supposed to end
up with like and what it is is that okay
I'm sure that we you know I think it
just scares the world okay sorry just
came back I worked out the weekly right
first because it's four weeks and then I
work out the hourly right okay
I'm part of the reason why it's just so
my calculator doesn't get too confused
when I do two divisions in a row first
number by the hours and then I did weeks
yeah that's one yeah that works too so
you can't 42 times yeah and like I said
that only that works because you know
what the number is right well the
question to say hints or otherwise find
the hourly right you probably only be
able to do it this way thanks cuz you
don't know what that holiday is all
right but there's a point
okay now let's have a look at the very
last question so here we go
now this is a 3-mile question three
months and you can kind of see just by
the way I've sent it out you can see
where the three marks are see that by
the way and let me just make him go
not that I expect you guys to have done
this already but if you could look at an
interesting paper write this kind of
question comes up all the time like this
is what this causes a map there's all of
this number e stuff here but it's that
way
all this number is stuff and then
someone draws a conclusion right and the
question is inevitable and why because
that's that's why were using that so we
can work out who's right and what the
right answer is so is she right in
thinking that the which option which you
want is the no retainer option the
higher Commission right so the three
much are for you can see them here in
fact let's have a look so the first
thing is you've got to work out well
what are each of the incomes right like
with or without the retainer and that's
two separate pieces right so I'm
expecting three marks there
someone has to work out there's no way
to avoid the third final mark is for
actually answering the question you
wouldn't believe how many people will do
these two things and then just stop
right because they're like well in the
textbook okay all I ever have to do is
just try to make actually wait you're
expected to draw a conclusion here it is
right and I'm going to use words I think
that's the easiest way to do it the
better deal is to take the lower
commission so unfortunately she's wrong
and he's why he's my justification she's
gonna earn this take away this more if
she takes the option with the retainer
okay it's a small margin in the scheme
of things but it's still better okay so
I'm expecting some kinds of words here
if you weren't sure how to word it well
there you go is wait
yeah that's fun though I guess I would
just be careful when I say first and
second yeah I think it's easy just to
say why identified which one it is but
just because you can change one of it
just sitting you know which one if I
said yeah but yeah unfortunately she's
made two along conclusion which lots of
people do and here's the massive one
okay